CBS this morning is looking into white
prices for many common items have surged
in recent years and today we're focusing
on the rising cost of alcohol going out
for a drink has get this never been more
expensive it's not only you since 2003
federal data shows a 57 percent spike in
the category they call the cost of
alcoholic beverages at bars and
restaurants so what is driving these
rising costs we traveled the country
hitting bars and barley farms along the
way in search of answers if you like to
drink
there's always an occasion why are you
drinking tonight but these days the bill
can be sobering we just spent fifty-two
dollars on couple drinks it's pretty
expensive to find out why we tracked
your drinks journey starting on a cold
day on the Northern Plains every
alcoholic beverage on the planet starts
on a farm like this barley farm in North
Dakota grain from these fields and silos
like this could be the source of your
next pint of beer or glass of whiskey
and farms like this are definitely where
your bar tab begins and welcome to the
end the world dances family has been
farming barley here for more than a
century give the big show nice this is
it what's all about that's what it's all
about right there Oh barley no beer how
much do you make per beer I make a lot
of penny a beer a penny a beer what a
pity all of this for a penny of beer for
penny a beer Lynn says that's about the
same as what his grandfather made I'm
pretty sure if your cost of your alcohol
is going up probably not happening out
here in North Dakota too much so what
about the brewers and distillers captain
while many claim their drinks are the
best or their cans or the coldest ice
later crisper taste it's hard to find
anyone calling themselves the cheapest
tasty treats but we found the makers of
America's alcohol actually have not
hiked their prices at least not more
than inflation and the proof is in a
store like this where people buy alcohol
for home the cost of a bottle
hard liquor at a store like this up just
14% since 2003 the price you pay for the
very same drink at a bar or restaurant
up 63 percent and you can't blame the
people who sell alcohol to those bars
and restaurants either so which is fun
is drinking them Jim cotton delivers
beer in Scranton Pennsylvania we were to
hear that the cost of alcohol at a bar
is up more than 50 percent in the past
15 years are you getting that a 50%
markup no you're not 50 percent richer
today than you were 10 or 15 years ago
absolutely not all of which leaves only
one possible culprit America's drink
prices are surging at the bar itself
where owners admitted to us that alcohol
is routinely marked up by 300 or even
400 percent meaning your $10 drink may
have originally cost 250 or less Sazerac
is my favorite drink in the world I love
to make you one brief tidwell is the
beverage director at Brennan's
restaurant in New Orleans we wanted to
see how she'd explain those rising
prices that's gonna be $13 $13 you got
it it's delicious yes $13 $13 I gotta
ask them this is a menu from two years
ago
okay 2017 I was here then it's a $10
right it is did well blame estate taxes
that is until we showed her a second
menu from 2003 this Sazerac is only six
dollars oh my god so the price is
doubled yeah since 2003 yeah so it's not
the farmer or the middleman or
manufacturer the price hike is happening
here it would seem yeah I agree with you
but you also aren't staying home for an
experience it's you're coming out and
unfortunately the guest does have to pay
for that in some way so do the bars and
restaurants more than a half dozen
owners we spoke with say even after
price hikes profits are slim that's
because of big shifts in the industry
including labor costs fewer workers are
being paid under the table and many
states have imposed higher minimum wages
bartenders these
they come with a giant resume and they
expect to make more money than ever and
so all of that ties into a more
expensive Sazerac some owners also blame
credit cards which are now used in about
90% of transactions those come with fees
and a paper trail for the IRS so the
alternative to a high cocktail price is
they're not paying taxes they're not
paying people and the drinks are bad who
wants that nobody yeah exactly yeah so
come to Brennan's have a Sazerac rakhis
is a whiskey drink with a rinse of
absence and a little bit of lemon by the
way you can buy a whole bottle for 30
bucks very cheap but first I want to say
thank you to the bar owners who helped
us understand this topic including Ralph
Brennan owner of Brennan's who I am
assured always pays his taxes
I do also put a lot of money into a
renovation recently so I understand what
the price went up there and it's part of
a bigger search so everything is going
more upscale and analysts call it
premium ization but my concern here is
if everything is premium where does a
guy go for just an affordable after
worth I'm a beer you have a date you
know maybe it's going nowhere or a
business meeting for that matter it's
pretty astonishing the price riser yes
yeah you can't always drink at home
especially when it's only coming from
one source I mean if it was all the way
down the chain you could understand it
better farmers know richer the middleman
is know richer the Brewers are not we're
making more money it's all happening at
the bar but they're not even making more
money they're actually just barely
getting by yeah again I say Shirley
Temple my drink of choice grenadine is
really fine
yeah there is no price hike and
grenadine you can enjoy the atmosphere
it will be after noon the next morning
enjoy the atmosphere